[Music]
now in give me my money news given
miletti give me my money [ __ ] submitted
by jake hopeless citizen california
won't woman wins a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in child support for
fifty two-year-old daughter
what does 150k how old is this lady
they're my seventy eighty yeah oh my god
what I mean what help support our fifty
two-year-old back taxes is it bad to be
giving grandkids
support unless are they special needs
the special needs yeah are they like
she's still taking care of this Oh
handicapped no shouldn't it be like
152,000 shillings or something shiny
rocks you got from like a billionaire
but it's only a hundred grand though 150
hunter fish maybe she's been fighting
the [ __ ] child support for such a
long time and it finally close kind of
oh my god that's inside we're dead
[ __ ] eighty year old husband that left
right okay so a real good beat this is a
wound for California Kelly up in here it
needs pays child support yes exactly
he flew he fled the country so Tony
Anderson is her name and back a long-ass
time ago her ex-husband left her with
her three-year-old and fled to Canada
and and so she tried to collect child
support she filed for it and everything
but he fled the country so we really
nothing that she could do at that point
called Interpol it was that Interpol
international police oh I think so I
don't do Europe though all right call
the [ __ ] mi5 mi4 at Mi three they're
supposed to call the Mounties the guys
with the Canadian with suits and the
Smokey the Bear on the horse I thought
they gave all their cereal Lone Ranger
people they just deferred it doesn't
have a James Bond na na Bullwinkle
[Laughter]
what actually did happen in the 70s so
70 is the court actually ordered him to
pay child support so it went through the
whole process and then he moved to
Canada so she couldn't collect and she
was like you know totally struggling
just focused on raising her daughter she
ended up creating a really successful
business and interior design so sick to
do it and they just kind of sat on the
back burner and she didn't think of it
she was just like I'm just Fox you know
and then like all sudden in her sleep
she was like I don't think there's a
statue of limitations on child support
and this is now 50 years later watch out
for those sleepy thought men she goes
and just checks it out and it was like
no and at this point he is living in
Oregon I know a lady or the guy the guy
this guy the lady's fine but she hasn't
let it go after 50 years the kid no its
father
no like he just bounced bounced so the
least they could do is send some money
yeah yeah no for sure what I'm just
saying that's what I would because I'm
looking at this child's face and
thinking of the [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
that fled the country because he like
didn't want to be responsible for
something to be things events led
Manteca 50 years later I think I already
cut you out of my mind you don't even
exist in my world oh that's the thing is
that she as time went on she's rending
part of her home now and she was
starting to run low on funds and so she
was kind of brainstorming ways to make
money and then she was like oh [ __ ]
child support
comes here to California she is on the
money yeah as long as you filed it as
long as you back before the child was
turned 18 and you filed for it and it
the court ordered it you there is no
statute of limitations and the person
that didn't pay has to now pay interest
and every year that went by there's more
and more interest stacked onto that room
and the court took into consideration
inflation so 150 blew this dudes like 70
years old 150 grand for 15 years so
that's 10 grand a year yeah yeah 15
years until he's 18 because he left when
he was 3 so 15 years that much money
cheap yeah 150 grand for the whole like
life of a child that kids supposed to
pay I mean for child support don't you
pay half so that means another 150
something live experience hold on I have
experience of my my dad used to pay my
mom child support okay he's $500 a month
back in the 90s they got divorced when I
was six so from 7 to 18 was at 11 years
so 11 years times 12 times 500 my dad
paid my mom 66 G's for raising me yeah
deal to raise a kid yeah yeah you can't
survive it also not all the labels about
this is what he paid my mom my mom asked
my dad for like 50 bucks a month and he
was like are you trying to rob me woman
[ __ ] cheap ass bastard all right well
yeah actually 30% you know that people
that are ordered to pay child support
out of all of them 30% get away with not
paying damn yeah my mom should have took
his ass to court I want to have more
money in life this is Tory and this is
her daughter was 52 year old oh that's
pretty inferred yeah
mmm holla at you they look good yeah I
don't know why
whatever dad look like I'm just curious
it was just a good her mind like you
know what I could still collect on that
hell yeah if I got child support and I'm
like 80 years old I'd be like let's
spend it all kids and grandkids and
great grandkids and great great-great
grandkids and she got the money of the
guy who makes the guy pay yeah cuz I'm
gonna be like you Oh hundred thousand
one entitled to 170 and then he settled
on 150 so he actually has 150 I guess so
it's in payments he's a little bit
panicked but she's like good I was
panicked for all of those years raising
our child yeah maybe he feels guilty
maybe he's got like esa's penance no I
think he's just like what he's trying to
cheat because he's cheap maybe I'll die
yeah for that first payment then to see
what happens you would he's forgot it be
in his eighties right yeah where is he
gonna go like it's an organ back to Kent
and then you go back to Canada at this
age well you know good for her I think
she's she's a smart woman
yeah me too I'm all for it cuz that's
[ __ ] up man raising a kid is already
hard with us too now imagine if you just
all by yourself that's some [ __ ]
yeah you could find a lot of ways to get
around child support - that's okay
that's why I how do people get away with
that let me know people say that it's
not easy to get the money yeah like a
win for I think my dad use child support
as a way to like punch my mom in the
face like everyday cuz I think my mom
was doubting that he was gonna pay oh
never at the beginning of the month he
would always write the check out and he
goes give this to your mom so I think it
was always like your buddy for your
dad's pity in that way we like let me
prove you bye kid I help you I even more
I will be response I know I don't know
the people are like well [ __ ] you if you
don't think I'm okay I'm not gonna pay
they're gonna run away but my dad give
me the check I'm like this from dad did
he draw like I'm thinking like a hand my
board says like four and it's like a
middle finger knows the
check all the times it gives to mom oh
yeah we're in check yeah very trusting
person when they were married yeah
thought of six they got divorced my dad
would like angrily give us money too
because he is like what do you think
what grows on trees
and you would get all mad does any of
you like here take it take it take do my
dad would [ __ ] tell me he's like you
know how much cuz I guess I was the only
kid that didn't have insurance at the
time when I was born so they had to pay
a lot of money out of it oh [ __ ] you
would tell me do you know how much money
you cost me holy [ __ ] I was like [ __ ]
it's not my fault you weren't [ __ ]
wearing a condom paired why not even
just like prepared with your finances
that [ __ ] put you on a child yeah you
should be grateful you have nine months
to figure this [ __ ] out
get your ass insurance yeah I'm so good
that's why you have that guilt Oh like
making my own money
ya know there it is you should thank you
I know cuz I always now you're not a
loser always like where everything is
50/50 I always have to bring my half
that's good for you so she keeps saying
right now she's like what can I do it
make more money I'm like your [ __ ]
stay-at-home mom what do you mean make
more money yeah tardy be drugs Bart
to count over Mary and I do want the
roofies do like if you're gonna rob me
you better roofie me yeah
roofie the [ __ ] I want to feel about
species [ __ ] that's one drug I've never
done before a roofie yes well I didn't
want to you guys ever get roofie like
let's say we're going to Vegas right and
you you feel like you know roofie can
you give me some of your drink oh my god
though if you've already been roofied
the effects don't work on you as much
really it's a one-time drug that's what
I heard mother it's too but I don't know
if that's true somebody tell somebody
about this couple I know they went to
Costa Rica was a mystery get I don't
know it was I think was Costa Rica and
they went to this like local bar and the
guy got drugged and he was like there
was a bunch of like locals around his
wife and he was all getting all scared
and and she I guess had been roofied
before and so she did it she do react to
the drugs but this is just all like a
story here so yeah this is all just yeah
I know you're crazy now cuz you
literally asked a question and you
answered yourself cuz you're like I
think was in closer though was it close
to go I don't know you know all kids
talk like that
listen I didn't have friends growing up
Gio so some of us had to have
conversations although I don't know if I
answer myself like I'll ask questions
without ads yeah you do in the closet
should I wear this I don't know doesn't
look good on me
I'm just in the [ __ ] bed like talking
to alright then I take it back I'm sorry
Nikki I'm a crazy [ __ ] you I don't
think we talked to us guys don't usually
talk out loud to themselves I do Steve
angrily mumbles to him yeah myself in
the car like if I'm driving somewhere
I'll argue with myself because I'm like
cuz if it's if it's another argument
that I had earlier and I'm just like
arguing like no that's stupid and then
I'm like playing yeah in the car I
probably have dashcam footage that's
awesome we're doing with myself at the
car yeah I I started yelling hard and
then I parked and I saw the cars next to
me looking at me and I started
pretending I was he's not rapping cuz I
got embarrassed call right now and in a
stop and I looked over there like
looking at me like that my mother
where the windows there is it I was
listening to this Deepak Chopra thing
they said for like enlightening and my
killer stuff no you have to quiet your
inner dialogue oh but you should have
like you should never be asking to
yourself you should just be like yeah in
the moment and not talk to you it's a
monkey mind man alright I'm with that so
but yeah I mean it's like preventing
your ruminations
but then sometimes you feel like I'm a
my idiot there's like nothing in my head
right now like zero that means it's good
you're in the moment I mean when you're
having dialogue you're in here and
you're not in the moment exactly
[Music]